Film Courage: How does a writer determine
their strengths and weaknesses?
Mark Sanderson, Screenwriter/Author: Good
question.
A lot of times a writer’s strength could…I
was thinking back to writing partners which
I had at one time for a number of years and
what our strengths were and my partner’s
strength was coming up with the idea.
He would have a dream and say “We’re having
coffee in the morning.
I have our next movie.”
That wouldn’t be such a strength of mine
because I am very picky about ideas and they
come few and far between for me.
Some people are like everything is an idea
for a movie.
It kind of isn’t.
You have to work more at some and others are
definitely not and just boom.
So his strength was coming up with the idea.
My strength was for us to be able to sit down
and write the idea you know structure all
this kind so he knew as well but I was the
one at the keyboard and so sometimes a writer
can also have a strength of dialogue.
So let’s say a partner is really good with
dialogue and the other is good with structure
or both of them are good at both.
But I think when the more that you write and
find what your strengths and weaknesses are
will be from what notes you receive over time
and time again like well structure-wise this
is off and your dialogue is great, your character
is meh…you know what I mean?
So you can only find out what your strengths
and weaknesses by doing it and then when you
find a weakness try to build upon that and
get better.
Make it a strength.
Film Courage: So it’s only by getting feedback
and if you don’t have a writing partner,
sending it out for notes, having a friend?
Mark: Yes or writer’s groups or a consultant
or someone to read it and you know these things
take time of course and let’s say your strength
is that you got to page 100 and you may have
all the strengths but everybody has a weakness
that has to be built upon to have it all be
built up at the same level.
What you want to do is calibrate that and
it will take time but I think from feedback
because you will see what am I not doing right?
What’s not hitting the mark?
Well your dialogue isn’t…it all sounds
the same.
I’m kind of weak at dialogue but I can really
craft a great structure that type of thing.
I think after two or three more scripts maybe
you start to say well I should really study
dialogue like we were talking about.
Record it and be out in the world, listen
to inflection, tone, diction (things like
that).
Film Courage: I am always shocked how…I
mean personal conversations people have on
cell phones.
I guess you could get some incredible stories.
I am always surprised people are willing to
share such personal information in a public
space.
Mark: Oh sure, and you only hear the one side.
Film Courage: And I’ve heard some doozies
in my time just being in a store and like
oh my goodness.
Either this person doesn’t care…
Mark: The test came back.
Film Courage: I’ve heard all sorts of stuff.
Mark: And you can only imagine what’s being
said on this other side.
Which is a technique in a scene too where
can only know what is on this side and our
mind type of thing.
Film Courage: That’s true because it keeps…I’m
thinking who is this other person on the other
end?
And usually it’s someone who is not doing
a lot of talking.
Mark: Or they don’t say “Hi Honey,”
or whatever it’s “What’s going on here?”
With that you’d say…I love how people
say “That’s a good idea for a movie!”
You go “It’s not, what is it?”
Okay it’s a kernel which could be built
but what is it about?
Or someone comes to your party and says “Hey,
you right scripts don’t you?”
“Yeah…when I can.”
And they go “I gotta good idea for a movie.”
You’re like “Great.
You should write it!”
And they go “Oh?
I’m not a writer.”
I say “Well you want me to write your idea.”
They say “Yeah, it’s great.”
And then they pitch it to you and you go “Yeah
okay.
I’ll think about it.”
And not to…but sometimes every idea is an
idea for a movie.
If it’s worked on yes.
Sometimes like we were talking about you hammer
it down and walk away, it’s not.
Question For The Viewers: Which part of the
writing process do you love?
Which part do you hate?